I believe Logan Paul's a big fan of the
Prime
I have noticed that Logan holding crimes
a lot I've noticed Logan drinking primes
a lot
just when I'm looking but that has been
something that I've noticed
[Music]
hey this is the game Triple H from the
WWE right now I am on snack Wars for
sport Bible I sort of feel like the top
is overkill
[Laughter]
so it's just like a pork rind yeah yeah
effectively
it looks and mildly smells like a big
butthole
that's probably more accurate yeah
and ironically taste
a little bit like a pig's butthole don't
ask me how I know that
tastes like fried fat
yeah that's that's effectively what it
is but it is yeah
yep
now we have
Jack Links beef jerky original
I'm a beef jerky fan a little known fact
Brock Lesnar has his own line of beef
jerky that's quite good
not bad soft easy to chew I'm going with
the jacklings
tough for me to enjoy fried fat
that looks like a pig's butthole
all right
nerds
rainbow flavor
all right yeah I'm going to start with
licorice I don't even need to taste it
not a fan of licorice
I'm going to take a small bite once
again very pigs butthole
adequately horrible
are you are you a candy fan genuine
generally I am not I am not nerds are
big in my household
my kids love nerds
it's almost like they made other candy
and whatever was left over they made
into nerds
tough to beat flavored sugar
too many
pills licorice every time not a licorice
man going to nurture
[Music]
lucozade
which I've had many of times
he'll start there
[Music]
now what I will say is for me
I'm not a fan of carbonated beverages
this is gas in it so to me this is not
my favorite flavor is nice the bubbles
kill it for me so you think that tastes
nice over here is is quite controversial
some people like it some people hate it
it's uh
[Music]
it's all right
it's your standard orange flavor to
drink yeah yeah I believe Logan Paul's a
big fan of the pride yeah UFC correct
foreign
[Laughter]
cough syrup but the fact that it doesn't
have gas in it winter Prime I do feel
like I won't cough for hours so you
think I like when we plays that you
picked his drink over the UK brand
he probably will
um I have noticed that Logan holding
crimes a lot I've noticed Logan drinking
crimes a lot
just when I'm looking but that has been
something that I've noticed
[Music]
are you aware of what a scotch egg is
Loosely well enjoy it yeah
I Loosely have no idea the full Contents
I think it's I think it's best we we
don't tell you what was that I think
it's best we keep that to ourselves yeah
yeah don't tell me I won't want to eat
it
there was a literal egg
inside the scotch wrapping
I'm glad I didn't get to the egg
I feel like a snack
is never good
if just on the outside you're not sure
if you ate meat or not
and I have eaten the product on the
outside before it gets to the egg
and I'm not sure if it's meat or not I
don't know so to give you an idea a
slang term for it is a fat man's Apple
fat man's Apple well they're probably
fairly accurate is that meat that is
indeed meat do you know what type I
wouldn't like to lie to you to be honest
so I'm not going to pretend yeah
so you guys have been eating these your
whole life you have no idea what's in it
popcorn chicken
I'm gonna go with a two-way unknown tie
on this one can I do that or do I have
to pick a winner no that's allowed but
if you had to pick a winner which one
would you if I had to push you for an
answer
I feel like there's less mystery
involved in the chicken I'm gonna go
with the kids
I don't know what's about to come out of
that egg if I got to the egg
already I know what wins I have no idea
what this one is
I want you to try it and see if you can
guess what's in there
all right
I have no idea some kind of cheese yeah
so that is um a Greg's sausage bean and
cheese melt it's a it's a UK favorite
what'd you think
not bad
not bad I only got the cheese I'll get
the sausage bit I don't think yet or
anything it's maybe packed in the middle
decent texture all right Burger King
it's a Whopper
all right
I can tell you I'm not a
a fast food connoisseur
what was this called again a sausage
bean and cheese melt a sausage bean and
cheese melt
in the moment I am going to go with the
sausage bean and cheese melt
as my winner though if
Burger King were to come on as a sponsor
I would definitely go with Whopper and
the USA one yeah
no yes the U.S one and here's the thing
of course it would win but that's why
everybody left to go to the America in
the first place I'm pretty sure that's
what the Revolutionary War was thought
about terrible food and the Improvement
in food quality in this modern times you
guys can get out of eating like Pig's
blood
stomachs and things like that just move
move on there's other ways to cook eggs
other than fried like right like there's
things that you can do to make food
taste better you guys do come to America
one time learn some tricks bring them
back people will love them
we were get I mean literally getting
threatened to be fired every week when
we would come back the fence The Rock
leaves the nation I become Triple H
leave DX we battle over the WWE
Championship like our careers sort of in
a way
marry each other